okay let's start the last section of our
speaker is the picker title from Google
Theater all right hi everyone I'm Peter
I'm a researcher at Google thank you so
much for inviting me and for attending
this afternoon's session I'm going to be
talking about federated heavy-hitter
discovery with differential privacy this
is a joint work with when on who was an
intern and Brendan hi changan way who
are all at Google but before I jump into
federated heavy-hitters let me try to
overview federated learning for those
who have not seen it because it's going
to be very important for the federated
heavy-hitters problem so what is
federated learning it's all about
learning on massively decentralized data
say for instance you would like to train
a smart Keyboard language model on
people's data and here we could be
talking about Android devices or others
now this is different from the classical
or standard distributed optimization
setting for many reasons and I've listed
them first it's we're talking about
massive decentralization here tens of
millions if not hundreds of millions or
billions of ices so a very large number
of devices these devices can be limited
on the communication side or on the
compute side so faulty low processing
speed low communication and the data can
be highly non iid so you don't have that
privilege of assuming that your training
on very structured iid data the
preferences of some people in some
country can be vastly different from
others and different parts and so these
are just some of the challenges and
hopefully you know this shows you that
there's a lot of novelty in this setting
now the way federated learning proceeds
is as follows you have all these devices
and we said there's a lot of them we're
going to sample a very small
action of the devices usually what we
look at our devices that are idle
they're not being used that are plugged
into the walls of battery is not an
issue and they are connected to
unmetered Wi-Fi so from that pool of
devices we sample a very small fraction
of devices and then what we do is we
ship a model to them you can start with
an untrained model so like randomly
initialized or a pre trade model on
public data set so you send that model
to the devices and then these devices
use their local caches so their local
data to do on device training so you're
going to train the model on your device
and then what they send back is not the
data and not the original model but just
the updates the direction in which
you've updated the model and on the
server side what you do is you sum these
updates you aggregate them and you use
that aggregate to update the original
model that you had and then you run this
multiple times you do back and forth
between randomly sampling a small subset
of the users sending them the model that
you have learned so far and then
learning on device and then sending you
their updates now notice something
already we are gaining a lot on the
privacy front because we're not
collecting sensitive data and one
important thing that I would like to
emphasize is that we're only getting
these updates and we don't store them
they're supposed to be ephemeral meaning
that as soon as they get aggregated sunt
they're deleted so that's already a big
win on the privacy front but there's a
little bit of yeah trust in the protocol
all right so one might rightfully ask
that these updates even though they're
not exactly that data but they were
computed on the data and we know that
training on data in some cases can over
fit so they do capture a lot of
information
and so one way around this issue because
we're sending these updates to a service
provider and say we don't as Jaya dev
said we don't want to place any trust
what we could do is we could use a
multi-party computation to do what we
want to do so let me here emphasize this
what the service provider wants to do is
just something so the aggregate is what
we are after and not the individual
updates so what you could do is you
could use secure aggregation which is
essentially a form of multi-party
communication to ensure that each
contribution coming from an individual
looks random in the eye of the service
provider if the service provider somehow
inspects that particular contribution
but then when they are added all
together you get the right aggregate so
somehow the noise cancels out so you can
see that we're using some you know
coordinate noise across the devices and
this can be done and a server mediated
approach all right so that's that's
hopefully you know resolving that
concern the other concern is even if you
compute the aggregate security using
this multi-party computation protocol
and you update the final model that
final model can potentially contain
information about a particular
individual and for that we can use the
popular technique of differential
privacy so what we could do is we could
do one should do both things on the user
device we limit the contribution of that
particular individual the way we do it
is we clip the l2 norm of that vector
that it's sending to the service
provider and then on the service
provider side we can add Gaussian noise
and using all the advancements in
moments accountant and others we can do
this training beautifully so there's a
nice paper that shows how you can do
differentially private language model
training in this federated setup
all right so again you do this until
convergence and then after you're done
and you've converged you can test the
final model that you obtained you can do
things like a be testing to make sure
that that model is doing well on some
public sets and then if you are happy
with the performance of the model you
could then deploy it to people's devices
and it could be further personalized on
their devices to look more like their
own preferences so you can do
personalization on top of this
Federation now the beginning this was
mostly you know a bunch of experiments
on publicly available datasets we tried
this concept on many datasets this is
just one experiment here on a
large-scale social network so that
there's 10 million public posts and
they're grouped by author we're
retaining an expert prediction lsdm we
tried multiple federated optimization
techniques you could do one single SGD
stuff on the device or you could do kind
of mini batch multiple epoch SGD on each
device and it turns out that if you do
the averaging with multiple epochs on
the device you could actually save in
terms of the number of communication
nouns that it takes until the model
converges more importantly you can show
that you get a slightly better
performance using that approach so this
was basically a proof of concept that
Federation despite the fact that we have
all these interesting differences with
regards that relative to the classical
distributed optimization setting it can
still work and you can still get a model
that performs well in practice now it's
not an idea anymore just on papers it's
actually used in production and it's
used in several ways I'll just show you
two applications one of them is on pixel
phones pixel devices and the settings we
have thousands of settings and choosing
how to display these settings can be
done using federated learning so kind of
Frank King and just displaying them in a
friendly way
another one that is also equally popular
as Google's keyboard which is known as G
board this is an application with a
little over a billion user you could use
federated learning also in the search
bar of G board to decide if you want to
show a result of search query or not to
the user yesterday is already yeah but
it mean how to rank what you're going to
see is essentially okay so yeah so these
are just two examples of use cases in
production there are others that we've
announced and this is all to say that
this is in production working at scale
now there's a lot of papers on this
topic and there are so many things that
one can look at you could for instance
try to improve the security protocol and
the multi-party computation that's
happening to make it more communication
efficient you could try to improve the
differential privacy guarantees using
better let's say accounting schemes etc
you could try to make sure that you
compress things efficiently so that you
do not communicate a lot of information
back and forth between devices and the
server so we've done a lot of research
on many different fronts and there's a
lot of papers but we're still working
very hard because there are so many open
problems in this space one of the things
that I would like to point out too is
the newly open source packet which is
called tensorflow federated this is
essentially targeted to academics
researchers mostly in academia to help
them get going faster on experimenting
with different federated optimization or
differentially private federated
optimization techniques so it does all
the design for you so that with a few
function calls in Python and tensorflow
you could get a simulation up in money
you don't have to essentially design the
whole system from scratch so it's
for deep learning or can you fit other
battles that's a great question so what
I'm going to be talking about today is
how do we go beyond just deep learning
the package is now mostly for training
deep learning models shallow or deep but
it's mostly for you know machine
learning and in this talk I'm going to
try to see to explore how we go beyond
that alright so this talk is about heavy
hitters it's not about deep learning so
I'm sorry to disappoint some but what I
said at the beginning is very useful to
kind of in terms of how we're going to
learn the popular items so let me just
briefly mention what this problem about
is about so the heavy hitters problem
assumes you have a data stream on
multiple devices each device has its own
data stream and the an analyst wants to
find what are the popular items in these
user-generated data streams for instance
in this case moon happens to be a
popular word because it appears on all
three devices alright so in this talk
I'm mostly going to focus on discovering
popular words but everything I'm going
to be describing can extend to other
things like URLs and other data types
does not have to be just frequent words
all right so if you want to do and this
problem I mean hopefully I don't have to
justify what why this problem is
important it can help in many different
ways for instance if you're designing a
smart keyboard you may want to learn
what are the trending words the popular
trending words so that you update your
vocab and you can do better
Auto completion or next word prediction
so it can have a lot of important
application in practice so in a non
private way the way we would go about
this is we would collect the transcripts
and the logs of people's data and then
we would let the service provider
compute the heavy hitters lots of ways
to computing heavy hitters and we would
just release the heavy hitters to an
analyst
but of course I mean especially in the
scrub you know that a lot of things can
go wrong and so if you would like to do
this in a private way you could use
differential privacy so instead of just
releasing the exact list of heavy
hitters you could use a differentially
private way this is a paper that goes
back to 2010 SEC kdd a Pradeep and Adam
probably there's probably other ways of
doing it
and at least now we ensure that if this
analyst is malicious even if she has a
lot of collusion power she wouldn't be
able to learn much about a particular
individual but this approach assumes
that the users have a lot of trust in
the service provider so it places a lot
of trust in the service provider and in
some cases maybe that trust cannot be
achieved cannot be met and in that case
perhaps those users might choose to not
participate simply because they don't
have enough trust in the service
provider and what that translates to is
the computation of the heavy hitters
might be biased towards other people who
don't care as much about privacy which
which would lead to all these biases and
they have a mutation so an alternative
approach is to use the local model of
differential privacy where you randomize
the data locally and you only send
randomized data to the service provider
in this case the service provider can
simply just join all these logs and give
the analyst the joint lock which is
which has been randomized and then the
analyst can compute the heavy-hitters or
find these frequent words this is
obviously much better on a privacy front
but we know and we've been hearing talks
for the past few days that this comes at
a harsh privacy utility trade-off
so all right so far we've seen these two
models and these are essentially the two
classical models of difference
privacy on the one hand you have the
central model which places a lot of
trust in the service provider achieves
good privacy trade-offs and on the other
hand you have the local model which
favors privacy but degrades utility so
my goal in this talk is to be if we
start from the left hand side because we
care about utility we want things to
work well in practice and we try to move
to the right hand side in the sense that
we try to as much as possible not place
a lot of trust in the service provider
improve the privacy guarantees while
retaining probably much if not all of
the utility guarantees it's really
privacy or is it trust
I mean privacy and Trust are I think
very like privacy we know how to measure
we have the definition with the trust we
don't have such qualitative measures
yeah that's a very good point I think
the wording can and should be improved I
agree it's aiming I guess what we're
trying to say is you would like to limit
how much the service provider knows
about every participating individual so
in this case because you're creating
this privacy barrier on the device you
can rigorously show how much information
can the service provider know about a
particular individual and in the other
case you're just sending the data as is
so you have full disclosure of data and
what we're trying to do is essentially
move from here to there as much as
possible
okay so and the goal is to try to see if
Federation can actually help us with
this process and how much can it help us
what can it bias and I would like to
remind you of the four essential
ingredients of Federation
there's subsampling we are randomly
choosing a very small fraction of the
users so there's that part we're doing
things interactively we're doing things
in multiple rounds and the two important
ingredients are these updates are
focused meaning that we're not sending
the raw data or just sending something
that we computed on the data like a
small little summary and they're
ephemeral meaning that they are not safe
they're not stored and so the answer is
that yes Federation can help secure now
I'm not using it no but you can you can
use it and I'll get to it so and the
question is if you do these practices at
the end of the day you get a lot of
benefits you get structural and k
anonymity and you get differential
privacy and the process of learning
heavy-hitters and you get good utility
privacy trade-off and I'll I'll be very
precise on all these fronts this is just
a bird's-eye view sorry it is so
confusing to me how complicated things
make things more private I mean for
example you did a sub something based on
as you said yourself when the cell phone
is back to the charge and whatever right
so if I'm a person who works at night
and sleep a day then you would know this
just by the fact that you that I
accepted this since that is running I
continue you know the more you
complicate things it's harder to argue
that it is a virus that so I don't get
why more complication is better no I
mean what I'm going to mostly discuss in
this talk is not going to be on the
production side mostly on the algorithm
side so I'm going to assume you're
randomly sampling from from the entire
population so perhaps we can talk about
this offline or at the end of the talk
of how you could implement this in ways
that are you know very closely related
to the description of the algorithm that
I'm going to talk about next
sounds like it's privacy from
conversations that we have had that
offline I suspect that's not where
you're going with this but if wondering
if you could just say a little bit more
about what the difference you see
between federated learning and and
little privacy these two things are
orthogonal local privacy is whether or
not you randomize the data locally
before you communicate with any external
entity federated learning is just saying
can you compute this function on your
local data set and give me the result if
that result leaks something about the
data that is on the device it's
there's a leakage there so these two
things are a thought you can couple them
you can randomize the output of the
result and send a randomized result back
to the service provider that's that's
one way of doing things so you can
combine local difference with privacy
with federate
okay so let me try to explain the
protocol I think and things will
hopefully be a bit more clear I'm going
to assume that there's only one word on
the device the you're going to see that
a lot of that I'm what I'm going to
present will naturally extend to the
multiple words per device in a bit so in
this setting I'm going to explain the
algorithm via a small little example and
we'll assume I have 20 devices and each
device has a single word in this
particular case Moon and Sun are very
popular because they appeared 4 x star
is a little less popular because it
appears three times and for the you know
for the sake of the protocol I'm just
going to append a dollar sign to denote
kind of the end of every word that's
just an end of word symbol so the
particle is going to proceed in multiple
rounds and each round there are three
stages and the first stage we're going
to randomly select a subset of the users
in this case I'm going to you know pick
10 devices at random so let's say these
are the 10 devices that we selected
that's the first stage and the second
stage it's the voting stage each one of
these devices is only going to vote for
one single character because we're in
round one we're going to vote on
character 1 to keep things simple so
what's going to happen is that s will
get three votes in this example M will
get two votes and then the remaining
characters will get and in digits will
get one vote each and so now what
happens in the third stage is you have
to threshold these votes anything that
is not popular you just discard and do
not consider and anything that is
popular you keep so you have a threshold
here theta and if the votes are larger
than theta you keep that character and
you place it in a tree for instance s
and M because they got votes greater
than 2 you keep them and the other
letters they got votes less than 2 so
you just prune them out you're not going
to explore those two
actions and that's the end of the first
stage of the first round so now you can
do the second round and in the second
round again you start by sampling
devices at random you're picking ten now
it's a new set of devices there might be
some overlap and in this stage in this
stage voting stage they're going to vote
on the second character but they only
vote if the word starts with a character
that has already been learned so if I
have a word that starts with a popular
character that I've learned in the
previous round then I vote otherwise I
remain silent so in this case su gets
three votes and st gets two votes mo
gets two votes and because they're all
above a certain threshold they get added
to the tree so now at the end of the
second round you've learned that SDSU
and mo are popular prefixes of a word
and you can keep on doing this multiple
rounds until convergence and at the end
for the sake of simplicity for this
example let's say you learn Sun and Moon
but unfortunately you don't learn star
even though it appears three times in
this population now there's a lot of
similarity between this algorithm and
the tree has algorithm of upper deep and
ref and a few other Yuri Kobe and I'll
get to that in a bit
but keep in mind here we're not doing
any local randomization and we're not
adding any noise we're just randomly
sampling and we're pruning
so just that at a high level this is the
algorithm n is the number of
participating users L is the length of
the longest word that you would like to
potentially discover and then there are
two parameters M which is the number of
devices that you're going to sample in
each round and we're going to choose
that to be some constant
at times root n so we're sampling root
end-users in every round and then
there's the threshold pita and otherwise
it's just you know a simple description
of the algorithm that I showed you just
to make that there make sure I
understand so the algorithm asks this
core is adaptively like you actually
need the round we're doing it
interactively at the end of every round
we declare the Tri the tree that we
learned with those popular prefixes and
in the next round the randomly selected
users can either choose to vote to
extend one of the prefixes by a single
character or to remain silent
maybe the reason you cannot get rid of
the round like being directivity as in
the trees that's a very good question I
have not exactly thought about it but I
assume you could yeah I assumed you
could by you know letting each user
choose a prefix of a certain length and
they would just vote for that so it's
going to become a little you know more
clear as I go all right so so the main
result here is that if you're looking at
the final tree that you learn with the
popular prefixes and words that is going
to be epsilon delta differentially
private and we have kind of the
relationship between the choice of m and
the choice of fade out with also the
length of the longest sequence data is
the threshold that you're going to use
in every round to kind of choose which
prefixes stay in which prefixes
so what's added and what's not add data
is the threshold factorial yes
yeah what does the tutorial mean what is
factorial no love is little one it has
larger than one yes they have an integer
larger
no well I'll get to it I'll show
experiments but you should think about
it this 20 or something like that
15:24 for you know the population sizes
that we've considered it's it's log it's
logarithmic and you know you could you
could make Delta be either 1 over N or 1
over N squared or even 1 over N cubed
depending on the choice of theta so if
you choose theta to be log n you would
get the roughly 1 by n Delta but you
could choose theta to be a 2 log N and
you would get 1 by N squared know how
are your picture I mean simulation what
I'm going to show some experiments
all right
so for instance this is to go back to
baths question if you choose theta to be
logarithmic in n you could target
epsilon any epsilon by carefully
choosing the gamma that's sitting next
to the root n in the choice of M and you
get Delta to be 1 by 100 then but this
specific choice of theta doesn't have to
always you know hope you could choose it
to be larger than log n you could use it
to log n for instance all right
and another thing is if you fix gamma to
be equal to 1 you could get kind of the
following guarantee which is your
epsilon is something like L by 10 a lot
1 by hundred n for Delta and I'm not
saying that this is the setting in which
you should use this algorithm this is
just one setting we have experimented
with you could choose your gamma and
your theta and different ways to get
stronger or weaker depending on the
application and the use case these are
just you know like some settings we've
we played with
gamma so what your sampling is M users
and you're going to sample a constant
and integer times root n that's gamma so
you can choose to sample two to ten or
three lieutenant you can set it to one
for instance in here I'm just setting
gamma to one or any questions held is
the length sorry yeah there's a lot of
things L is the length of the longest
word so you're going to run this
protocol L times that's the depth of the
tree the results also contain the
partial or is it just like the full
recovered words like that's a great
question yeah I'll get to it this is
this is for the final tree but I'll get
to it in a bit great question
all right so so what we're doing in this
is we're choosing worth voting on
characters and we're doing it L bounce
now if you don't want to vote on
characters if say you want to vote on a
single bit that's going to mean that
you're going to have to run more rounds
right so there is in some sense and it's
captured by L all right so and this is
again just a table showing some of these
trade-offs between what's your you know
how many users you have how many users
you're sampling and what do you want to
target for different else I'm gonna skip
this to make sure I get to all the
questions so one of the concerns here
this perhaps also goes back to Kobe's
comment is that and maybe to also ORS
comment that you're sampling people and
you know who you sampled right you can
link these votes that you're getting on
one character extensions of this tree to
particular devices so one way of
resolving this issue is perhaps using
trusted shufflers or secure aggregation
to securely aggregate the votes so you
can use multi-party
competition in addition to this protocol
in order to ensure that you know the
votes are not linked back to the
individuals that are participating in a
round now the other thing this is to go
back to the question that I got is in
you know the result that I stated I'm
referring to the tree that is seen by
the analyst this is what you release at
the end of the date and differential
privacy holds here now the service
provider gets to also see these one
extra characters that are not
necessarily popular that did not get
enough votes to cross that threshold and
so this may not necessarily be
differentially private and in order to
resolve this issue and make sure that
the service provider does not even see
this tree you could use threshold
cryptography so this is a work in
progress so I don't have much to say on
it but again leveraging multi-party
computation you could do the voting step
using threshold cryptography level 20
morphic encryption all right now this is
something that wrath brought up which is
I'm fixing my choice of theta to be log
N and I'm fixing gamma to be one so I'm
getting a delta which is roughly 1 by n
sometimes we want a stronger guarantee
so you could choose a larger theta to
get let's say a Delta on the order of 1
by n squared again something like 2 log
n would would take you to that regime
you can choose it more or less of course
it's going to have some impact on
utility and we can measure that all
right so these are the three concerns
you might have perhaps other concerns
and I'm happy to chat offline to you
know learn more about what you like or
dislike about this approach all right so
one thing I want to emphasize is we try
to compare this to local differential
privacy and in particular because our
approach is also building tree we wanted
to compare to the previous protocol and
I'm not going to do justice to the paper
or the to the previous protocol but out
of
very very high level what you're doing
is each user is choosing a random prefix
of their word and they're sending a
locally differentially private version
of it and then in the decoding stage
you're traversing again a tree from the
root to the leaf and anytime you hit a
node that has counts that fall below a
certain threshold you're just going to
prune and not explore that path and so
at the end of the day you would only go
all the way to the bottom exploring
paths that have enough counts that are
popular again I'm not doing justice
there's a lot more happening beautiful
paper so in the paper there's a
comparison kind of analysis that they do
on the NLT kay Brown corpus and so here
you have 10 million users so what they
do is they draw 10 million words they
fix the length to 6 characters and at
the end of the day you get about 26,000
unique words and the definition of the
heavy hitter in that experiment is if a
word appears more than 15 root and then
it is a heavy error so in this case if
it appears more than about 47 thousand
times then this is a heavy hitter court
and if I'm correct there's about 25
heavy hitters something like that so I
should also do for this experiment the
major bottleneck was my laptop
all right so in that experiment the
setting they were choosing is epsilon
equals to its pure local differential
privacy and the results they were
getting as a recall rate of 0.8 6 and a
precision of 0.2 for the precision is
too low it can be enhanced if you have a
dictionary and you can expect where
these words you know are coming from so
we didn't want to compare apples to
oranges because you cannot just compare
pure local DP to a central DP guarantee
so we used the latest and greatest you
know results privacy amplification via
shuffling to translate that epsilon
equals to pure local DP to a central DP
there's there are many ways in which you
can translate it to translate it
depending on how you choose Delta this
is one just choice and so two comma zero
local DP can be translated to zero point
zero to four comma 10 to the negative 14
central DP alright so in we tried our
approach and we fixed the Delta and we
were trying different values of epsilon
and we started reducing epsilon and and
you know we got to about point zero
three and the precision and recall were
still at one and then when we went down
to point two fort to do the sphere
comparison we got to 0.95 recall and
precision of one now I have to emphasize
something that this is still a bit of an
unfair comparison because I mean on the
one hand typically what you want is
something single-digit Epsilon in the
central model and so in that case these
shuffling results are not going to be as
effective as in this case here the
amplification gain is very strong
because you're starting with
single-digit Epsilon and so that is
still kind of a bit unfair of a
comparison but I wanted to point this
out all right so let me just quickly
tell you how you extend this one thing I
should also tell that
medicine is not complete still because
there's another algorithm for the same
problem the Apple paper so that
comparison also should be done my guess
is that that might look better than what
we have tree has does not necessarily
the very best the latest and greatest
algorithm so we should look into the
others I just want the tree yes because
it's it has the kind of similar
structure the algorithm itself so people
have more questions bail of them all all
right
so multiple words it's it turns out to
be actually an easy thing what you do is
you just sample a word locally so let's
say you have all the stream you can
choose one at random locally and you use
that word if the device is sampled in
this participating and you can show that
the same privacy guarantees would hold
in this case so if you have many many
words and you're selected you just
choose one at random so let me show you
our experiments we use the sentiment 140
data set this is mostly used in NLP for
sentiment analysis it's a relatively
large data set of six hundred fifteen
thousand users it has about 1.6 million
tweets and we use two metrics to measure
utility we use the discovery rate which
is if a word appears at a certain
frequency in this entire data set what
is the probability of our algorithm
finding it as a function of its
probability and we used also recall as a
metric so for the single word case we
can compute the worst case discovery
rate this is a simple probability
calculation if you assume that every
word is not going to have a prefix
similar to any other word you can say in
the worst case what's the probability of
discovering it if it appears W times in
the data set and then you take that
probability to the power L so that's a
very simple calculation that gives you
just an empirical expression for the
worst case discovery rate under our
algorithm but we actually ran
experiments on the sentiment 140 and you
can see that there's a bit of a gap
between the worst case probability of
discovery rate and the actual thing and
what this is saying is say under epsilon
equals two if it appears roughly about
you know 0.1% of the time you can find
that with a discovery rate that is close
to 1 you can also look at recall rates
and you can see that with single-digit
epsilon say epsilon equals 8 we can find
the top safe 300 or 300 something words
a recall rate of 1 so like we can
perfectly recover those top 350 words
with single-digit Epsilon you could also
look at the multiple words the results
are essentially very similar and one
thing we did which is quite interesting
experiment was to take a white list that
we have that contain 260,000 words and
just delete them from the data set and
try to find the out of vocab words this
is a harder problem so in this case what
we're doing is we are taking the
sentiment 140 data set we're removing
all the words in a dictionary of size
260,000 and we're left with a lot less
words that are perhaps more personal
kind of words they are not as frequent
as the popular ones like ate and went
and Kate you know these things and so we
tried to rerun the whole thing with
recall rates and you can see that we get
slightly worse performance on out of
vocab performance but nonetheless it's
still impressive that with single-digit
epsilon we can get the top 100 words on
a small data set by the way when we
remove those in vocab words we lost
already 160k users so there's like 160 K
people with tweets that are all in the
dictionary that we have all right with
that I'll come to end I just want to say
there's a lot of open questions I
touched on these shufflers and
multi-party computation to do this in a
better way with better privacy
guarantees stefano is here and shawn is
here so after the talk after the session
if you have any questions you would like
to tell us what you think about this
we're more than happy to discuss and
there are so many ways we can
collaborate to move this to a better
place
Thanks
[Applause]
time for three questions have any
questions so what I understood your
where your algorithm kind of replaces
the frequency estimators from the tree
started with them with something else
but like the please reduction from
frequency to heavy hit oh that's kind of
the same right so the discovery part is
very similar except that entry has
you're randomly choosing a prefix and
you're randomizing it we're not
randomizing anything right so the
process sorry the decoding part order so
like the previous you can view as a
reduction from an algorithm that allows
you to estimate frequencies into an
algorithm that can identify the city so
from right and those to do replace the
thing that estimate counts but then
aggregated them right that part is I'm
ready on yes
till it's time to go
[Applause]